okay so i i heard a story about like
spike's so crazy you're driving on the
highway and he just like
just he's driving and then he dives into
the back seat oh my god
yeah like um so this is when we were
doing the bike like so spike got me the
job at freestyling magazine like i was
just graduating i would come out and
visit him on spring break when i was in
college the last two at least and saw
what they like it was just three dudes
making this [ __ ] great magazine
that i grew up looking at and i'm like
[ __ ] i wanna that's what i wanna do so
my senior year i just
revam i just made the
design professor
uh she she helped me put a magazine
portfolio show i could lay out a
magazine even though that i wasn't a
graphic design student i just shifted
thinking i want to do this
so i
took it on myself and didn't even get
grades on that [ __ ] like i was just
single working with my design professor
and uh and it paid off because right as
i was graduating
they needed a new art director
but that's not the story anyway so then
i get hired and we're having a great
time making this [ __ ] bike magazine
and we were going down to shoot
uh do a photo spread with matt hoffman
and we're going from uh torrance to
uh san diego okay uh matt was gonna be
in uh
there's i can't remember what the ramp
was but we were gonna meet at a ramp and
we had the big air [ __ ] it was before
that way before that uh and so we had a
big so we're in a chevy astrovan this is
the company astrovan it said freestyling
down the side
and uh
we had this a couple of bike boxes which
are big you know shoved between the
consoles so there was the two captain
seats and then it was a cargo van and
the
um well it was a cargo van that had not
a cargo man it just had seats but the
bike box was jammed right up against
between the two
front
seats and spike put the thing in cruise
control and we're shooting down the 405
heading towards the 5.
he's going 80. there's no traffic but
we're just flying down the uh
freeway and he's got in cruise control
and he's like hey can you hold the wheel
for one second so i hold the wheel and
he flips the seat back and back rolls
out and runs to the back of the van and
won't come back
and so i'm steering this thing and i
can't there's a [ __ ] bike box that's
wedged in right here that i can't just
slide over and get into that seat
without like you know i have to kind of
ghost ride i had to climb over and get
through that i'm not the most flexible
limber person to [ __ ] do that
but yeah he never came back he sat back
there and just was ready to die she says
that's crazy man [ __ ] he also like we
this is way later this is uh
uh two
[ __ ] why don't we do it it was right
before jackass three but it was summer
it was when we did the um 24 hour
takeover of empty
we decided we're going to film this um
tribute to evil knievel matt hoffman was
putting together this tribute to evil
knievel and we were trying to so spike
and knoxville i go to oklahoma
and uh knoxville had rented a big um
crown vic
and spike flew in late like so he gets
there and we're on our way to the
location oh no this is the this is
leaving location that day where we would
film a bunch of crazy stunts uh spike
says let me drive that he loves crown
vicks
so so he takes he knoxville gives him
the keys i'm riding in the backseat
knoxville shotgun spike's driving
rent-a-car crown vic
and we're
about to get onto the freeway and he
looks
and there's it's like a clover like a
big looping uh ramp to get onto the
freeway
and there's a big mound almost like a
skate bowl
of dirt you know grass around that ramp
so we start
going in and then he just floors it and
rolls into the bowl off the ramp and
into the grass and starts
like we're getting cheat out like like
just carving a bowl
in this crown vic
it's not 80 70. i don't know how [ __ ]
fast and as we're cruising around all of
a sudden
like you just hit something i don't know
if it was a dip or a rock i don't know
what but then we
skated down and got onto the freeway and
we're cruising on the freeway and we're
just watching the temperature gauge just
start to
fly up
and spike like look at that i'm like oh
man that's going fast it's like you can
see it move so we're like oh that's not
good and then the red lights start going
and then car starts like dying and dying
we're just driving it until not even
trying to
like pull over we're just trying to get
to where we need to go
and then the car seized and so then we
just left it on the side of the road and
we passed it every day for the next
three days because none of us were going
to call it in
we flew home and then shawna had to
figure it all out
one of many vehicles yes and that was
all spike right
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]